it's really interesting how i hear this
a lot that uh
i was talking about anti-racism trying
to explain to people that
there's racism there's and that so
on one side you have racism then in the
middle you have not racist and then on
the other side you have anti-racism
anti-racism and racism agree on many of
the same constructs
they just disagree on who should benefit
from them i guess actually it doesn't
really make sense because
anyone can be racist but in the
anti-racist worldview like the ibrahim
x-candy guy he views it as
racists and anti-racists agree on the
exact same things
except who should be benefiting the most
from it and so i think we you know we
we want to be not racist i mean we've
been doing really really well for a long
time
but now they're recreating all the
identical systems and under the guise
of getting rid of them the one thing i
find truly fascinating about it is if
you compare what they're saying now
to say the dream of martin luther king
jr it's completely at odds with
everything he said
so it's the weirdest thing to me when i
see people holding up you know signs and
protests referencing
you know martin luther king jr and i'm
like but you don't agree with him
you disagree with him it's gone
completely their direction yeah i don't
know if you saw
martin luther king's was it his living
daughter
she had a post on his niece
okay she had a post that she did on
twitter i just couldn't believe it it
was a picture of a
young black man holding a sign uh what
are the signs say it said like dear
white people stop using martin luther
king
to further your agenda you know you
killed him too
yeah yeah yeah yeah and that was just
the most shocking thing because
as people rightfully commented like i
would like to be judged by
the content of my character rather than
the color of my skin
it was the poster being held was doing
exactly the opposite of what martial
king
suggest we do dear white people
that's just group blame that's right
original sin for an entire group of
people that's the exact opposite of what
the civil rights movement was based on
so my prediction i guess is the olympics
will be a whole bunch of men
biological males well according to
wikipedia men adult human males there
will be
i i actually you know what let's we'll
go into this because this is like it's a
weird
it's a weird thought the olympics
allowing
you know male individuals to compete in
the women's division
won't that just over time create two
divisions
the men's and the trans women's division
i mean basically it depends on if they
want to just well
over time yeah i mean basically because
the women's division will essentially
just
be dominated by males yeah a lot of
these trans activists in sports though
they don't even want to have these
different categories there's some
there's a
movement to just eliminate the
categories and base it on just like what
like weight or something like that
which would still eliminate female
sports because even
controlling for a weight at every stage
of the you know
qualifying it's much more dominated by
males at every weight class you know i
learned this uh uh
i think it was like a year or so ago i
was doing an interview with uh dr
deborah so
and in the course of the research for
the segment we did like a 10 minute
interview and then we
we put together sources and context in
between some of the things you were
saying
i didn't know this but it wasn't until i
think the early 90s
we when we did clinical trials for drugs
we didn't
include women it was just men and so
surprise surprise some drugs weren't
working on women because women have
different bodies
and and so uh i think one of the big
one of the big issues was painkillers
for instance men and women react
differently to different
medications it wasn't until the 90s we
were like hey wait a minute
we might have to do clinical trials for
men and women yeah
that's a good argument for things like
well if i wanted to steal man something
like
feminist studies or whatever in medicine
i would point to things like that where
it was like yeah
we need to look at you know the female
aspect of things was not emphasized
quite as much
uh and it's good that we can look at
that and maybe it's good to have a
you know people who are looking at it
with an eye for these sort of types of
discrimination that maybe a bunch of
guys would just kind of look past yeah
but you see a new movement
now that's basically claiming that
there's something called feminist
science
that is distinct from normal science and
it can only be done by
can only be done by females uh which
gets rid of the whole universality of of
knowledge and
you know if you're gonna get a different
result based on your your biological sex
yes then this isn't science this is just
politics i love it when
when they say things like two plus two
doesn't equal four because who who made
that up
and there's a viral video where it's a
black lives matter activist saying like
something like so what some white guy in
europe said before and all of a sudden
everyone just says okay that's
ridiculous and it's like
actually no i think it was it was the
middle east
you know we use arabic numerals but uh
uh it was multiple cultures coming with
the concepts of
numbers yeah uh well that's where they
go
man and it it you know what you know
what's really interesting is that when i
bring up that
we finally realized we need to do
clinical trials on women
that's a good thing and that's a that's
a representation uh you mentioned this
of like act of feminist
studies or whatever in a positive sense
that there was a point where it was kind
of like hey wait a minute i just
realized something
if we have a bunch of like just one you
know group of people from the same town
from the same school all sitting in a
room they haven't been exposed to
other you know parts of the world and
different experiences there's a lot they
don't know
and that's diversity of opinion
diversity of thought
so you end up saying you know what would
really help if we got someone from a
different
school to come in here and talk to us
because they have a totally different
you know uh like we're researching the
same things
but i don't know what they've been
talking about what they've found if we
send one of you know one of our dudes
over there and one of their dudes comes
over here
we'll all be more robust in our ideas
and our perspectives
and that was what diversity was supposed
to be when we talked about diversity of
bringing in you know migrants
and different people from different
backgrounds it was because they're
different world views yeah
but now what they're doing is they're
like so long as everybody looks a little
bit different
we don't care yeah actually actually we
want them to be homogeneous in thought
that's what i think is going to be the
death knell of a lot of universities
in fields like psychology where you have
people who are almost entirely from the
left and sometimes very far left
who are just doing these studies that
are a lot of these studies even
when they if they study politics they
almost look at conservatism as if it
were like
uh an aberrant trait you know they study
at like an alien study
yeah they're just like strange why would
anybody believe these things
uh so you can see that bias there um
and it's just they're unable to cover
for their own blind spots because
you're gonna have i mean science a lot
of people try to portray it as this
emotionless thing where you know
scientists are just going in there leave
all your biases at the door
i'm just looking in my microscope and
you know eureka that's not how
there's there's a human aspect to it
people have biases they want their ideas
to be true
and the way we control for that is by
having a diversity of opinions or people
who can then check your blind spot and
say like
actually you didn't check for this you
didn't check for that you know
take in these different viewpoints but
as what you said we're not getting that
type of diversity we're getting
superficial diversity of
let's just skin color if i dedicated a
year
to doing research and i put my heart and
soul into it
who are you to come in and tell me
that's wrong that would trigger me
and thus shut your mouth and let me just
believe i'm right cause it'll be happier
right
i'd be happier too i mean i had ideas
turned out not to be true when i was
studying the moon is made of cheese and
i can definitively prove it
and then you go back and create a fake a
revisionist history of how
we've all heard the moon is made of
cheese well now we know for sure
can't prove it's not that's right
correct redefine cheese too
yes yes we just rock and well that's
that's that's that's a big thing about
what they do and i i've been talking
about for a long time
with with the words gender and sex
changing changing the definition of the
words allows them to change law without
having to vote on it
so i mean we've kind of we kind of just
seen this with the supreme court
when they ruled recently i'm sure you
heard that uh
your sexuality and your orientation are
inherent components of sex therefore
you can't fire someone for being trans
and you can't fire someone for being
uh you know lesbian or gay because those
are fundamental components of sex
and so thus it's not necessarily the
same thing but it's
really reaching and saying you know if
if x plus you know circuitous way to get
there
right for sure yeah i think i think it's
only a matter of time before
you know uh gender as
i i think it's obvious to most people
was was was put on documents
so that we knew if you were male or
female for very specific reasons
that's what people have meant by gender
from a legal standpoint anyway from a
very long time it's only
very recently where now all of a sudden
it's a state of mind
so uh you probably know this better than
i do lydia but i was told that
in emergency medical treatment knowing
whether someone's male or female is
extremely important
yeah it is and i wish i could tell you
more definitively why but i never
worked in an emergency department all i
remember is nurses telling me about
needing to know whether they're gender
different medications i imagine
yeah but but different dosages and stuff
but also in like
uh if someone's laying on the ground and
you don't know what's wrong with them i
was reading something where it's like
it's really important when the emts show
up that they can clearly distinguish
whether or not
this is male or female for a variety of
reasons so i wonder what would happen if
in like new york where they recognize i
think 31 genders
and it's really weird because they do
and some of them are the same like they
have female to male but they also have
ftm
which is just an acronym for female to
male 1 and then they have something
called
uh i'm not saying this to be
disrespectful it's literally gender
blunder
is one of the recognized uh new york
city genders what what is what is it
what is an emt or a doctor gonna do
when there's uh you know a non-binary
androgynous individual and they're
trying to determine
an emergency procedure with only seconds
to decide and the form says gender
blunder
and there's gonna be like i i'm not sure
quite exactly what i should
do yeah i mean if states want to go and
have people put
their gender identity on their ids in
addition to their sex
yeah whatever i don't think it really it
doesn't give anyone information that
they need to know in any context like we
have traits on our id
so that we can be you know that person
has blue eyes brown hair
is a male these are things that people
that can be verified and you can you
know
this is what the individual looks like
but to put you know i'm genderqueer or
something
that's not something that anyone can
look at you and know about yourself i'm
not sure why you'd be like you know
that'd be like putting
you know boxers or briefs on your ideas
like there's no reason
for people to know that about you or
your political identity
like identity isn't relevant on an id in
any way
but if they want to put if people want
to do it they can put it on there but we
can't replace
biological sex with it because that's
something that's very important the
problem is
i don't care what other people do okay
you want to put an x on your id because
now a lot of places are allowing this i
really don't care i'm gonna
my my own business if you want to put
your identity on your on your id and you
put gender blender or
you know androgen is another one they
list in new york city i it doesn't
affect me personally
but i have a concern then if it comes to
medical treatments and the doctor can't
make
think about it this way a million people
go through the medical system in new
york in one year
it's a random number i don't know the
actual number is let's say uh
one percent so you get ten thousand
people who
are of a variety of gender
right non-binary gender blender whatever
they everyone goes in the hospital and
there's a certain percentage of success
and failure for the doctors
on a variety of ailments if they don't
know
your biological sex they can they can't
be as effective
so hypothesizing you may end up with a
disproportionate amount of
non-binary individuals succumbing to the
ailments versus
uh i guess typical binary
biological sex is male or female
normally i would say
if you choose to do this and the doctor
can't properly treat you
i mean you make your own choice i'm not
going to intervene in your life the
problem then is
someone's going to pull up the data and
say look at this there's there's you
know
it is twice as likely that a non-binary
person dies in a hospital compared to a
a cisgendered person
that proves the doctors are killing
these people and are biased against
them that's the issue yeah i thought
about that but that's definitely
that is the narrative that we're going
to see if that absolutely happens yeah
i'm afraid of that
and doctors already pay so much in
malpractice insurance and we're already
such a litigious society and nurses
already do
so they spend so much of their time on
charting there's just going to be more
for them this is just going to make
everything objectively worse
it's like not good again because they're
only measuring
after the fact they're just looking at
the final numbers do they
they just get alerted they match across
the top
no one's lower than the other is that a
minority group yes discrimination
and this is actually going to be uh it's
not just about medical practices but
there's also
it's going to manifest in a lot of
different ways perhaps police
you know stops or something you know
somebody who dresses a certain way
is more likely to get stopped and then
they're going to draw the conclusion
not based on the real reason but they're
going to look at the macro level
outcomes and say
this proves discrimination yeah which is
if you know people are dying then that
proves it they're biased
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live monday through friday at 8pm so
come back to check us out when we go
live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you